so I'm signing today oh I was trained as
a physicist so actually like Sean I
realized that all my degrees are in
astronomy hmm as well I did cosmology
Chicago which is very much shot and
while I was at Chicago I became
increasingly interested in branching out
I had read of course many of the books
written by people in this room and I
ended up doing a lot of work in animal
and human behavior and ended up at the
Santa Fe Institute and it's actually
it's much easier to study human behavior
because humans leave records of their
behavior everywhere
and because I was a cosmologists I had
no problem studying historical events
that I couldn't do experiments on or
social systems that are so large you
can't do experiments on so I had none of
they I ever work in a lab I don't see
why you need to work in a lab to learn
in the world and so yeah I being having
grown up as a physicist I was a plate in
hysterics probably still an and one of
the things I do when I work on social
systems is I try to take the methods and
ontology x' of physics very seriously
and in physics of course you can have
objects and believe they're they have no
composit parts and then later you
discover they have composite parts and
this is not distressing at all that you
discover the proton is is not an
elementary particle so when you come to
study social systems often and I should
say I when I was an undergraduate I took
a class with Hilary Putnam who was I
didn't know this but he was a
functionalist and I didn't know you had
to invent functionalism it just seems so
obvious that it had to be true that the
brain was a computer and that you should
understand thoughts mental states the
sort of objects of moral intuitions as
computations and so it was striking to
me that it had to be invented by
somebody and that person was in the room
and oh ok oh that's that's a tough one I
just I just gave the introductory
lecture on this subject in my intro
course so I could - well I'll say it
explain any workings but but well the
the idea that mental states what we
consider to be the the act of thinking
is multiple realizable in different
objects as long as the
the structure that object has the the
the subparts that objects have the same
functional roles as the original let's
say brain that you're modeling it's I
think the the intuition behind why we
think artificial intelligence is is
possible exactly so there's all sorts of
you know I take your neurons I spy
slowly replaced them by small silicon
chips would be the same thing I make it
Bluetooth I take a little box that's
your brain right all the things that are
performing the computation the biology
of the i/o is sort of extraneous what
we're striking so but maybe it matters
what maybe it matters how they're
embedded in the world right so it's just
me or structural isomer morphisms
probably not another enough so this this
was actually it so see the fact a that
had to be invented in the fact that he
was not talking about the Twinner
thought experiment
which we can talk about as well but the
the idea that actually this might not be
true the thinking just staying in the
head was his phrase well so this is this
is this is an excellent question so this
is one way we get to what seems to me to
be the strange fact about naturalism I
think if you are a naturalist you you
you you take a century functional
position if I download you and your
computer I have to treat that computer
with respect I can't delete you but when
I came to study social systems archive
all of you but no so one of the things
that's striking is okay fine you if you
know the brain is a computation I can
find lots of computations and social
systems and I think first of all this is
the solution to some of putnams
objections to pure internal
functionalism but when I study a social
system I sort of reverse-engineer it I
try and find the underlying computation
sometimes those computations involve
multiple brains at the same time and
that to me seems very strange so there's
a computation that floats around it's
not attached to any particular person
what's it like to be that computation
and I I don't have a good answer for
that it is
well I I you know I know what it's like
to be me I feel although it's funny we
talked about the Buddhist intuitions one
of my students I was trying to explain
when I was gonna say to you guys to her
and she has said a lot of Eastern
philosophy and none of this made sense
to her the intuition that there are
mental states that mental states have
functional relationships to each other
and so I had a conversation with
somebody who claimed not to have mental
states which is the opposite of the
zombie intuition where everyone's trying
to convince you they do have mental
states and you know experiences of what
it is like to be somebody so in any case
that it's sort of a roundabout way to
say that I do a lot of mathematics and
the social sciences but I do it from as
if I was a physicist sorry I use I used
tools like group theory if you go into
the social sciences from what you might
call the hard sciences everyone expects
you to be very good predicting things
because that's the gold standard if you
can predict how it organism is going to
behave and it they think you know what
it means and I tend to focus much more
on explanation so that's that's one of
the sort of distinctions that I make
whenever I have to explain what I do in
a pedagogical system so any case yeah I
suppose if I was willing to give
something up or what I might be willing
to change my mind on you know if you
have courage you should be willing to
change your mind on something that you
couldn't imagine changing your mind on
and so the idea that you can have a
scientific theory of mentality of
thought of consciousness that didn't
simply reduce to a story about
computation about the function of
relationships between different parts of
your brain if that were possible if it
were possible not to believe that and
yet not to believe in mysterious mind
mist that penetrates and has special
relationships and neurons or to some
biochemical phenomenon if we're possible
to believe that without without being
supernatural I I would love to and then
it would solve a lot of my problems
about for example drink computations and
what does it like to be a conversation
[Music]
you